yeah I can only imagine man because like
you know I got a family I got kids and
[__] I'm like bro I would never want to
be uh I mean I feel like the type of
[__] I do I I purposely don't touch
certain [__] because I don't want to
like over expose myself I guess and my
kids and my girl and [__] so I even told
Adam when all this shit's been going on
the last few weeks I was like bro you
got some [__] thick skin brother
because
this [__] is crazy they would have been
on your ass if you had gone over there
permanently yeah
but even just like just seeing like you
know because I know Adam I could um
addressed whatever allegations over and
over so I'm like yo this [__] got
brought back up and I'm like bro here's
here's the thing and I want your opinion
on this yeah
I genuinely believe that if Adam had not
gone on that pod right when I was on
there and fired me in the very
unceremonious manner in which he did
a lot of that [__] wouldn't have
happened I agree and I think I might
have said something to that effect on
the podcast I think you might have yeah
I did I I did I did say something like
that I was like because because I I do
think that that moment was so viral and
it also highlighted
whatever
said issues that and I even told Adidas
when he was on here I was like you were
planning on leaving because there's no
way thick-skinned ass like A.D I know
got so mad about someone saying he has
four jokes that he quit like he was
planning this [__] you know but but
here's the thing A.D for show was and
I've been telling him he should leave I
told him and t-rell like you guys should
be the [__] La drink Champs and they
and they got their own thing going it's
going really well for them here's the
thing
it kind of forced a.d's hand it did with
it being published and when it was also
a nice opportunity if you were planning
on leaving already and those Wheels
already in motion it was a nice
opportunity to kind of take advantage of
the of the you know the virality of the
moment and I think it was Mutual I think
that Adam and no jumper was wanting to
Pivot away from that considering they
are at a certain point is a conflict of
interest when there's other podcasts
with I don't want to say regurgitating
but utilizing right the same content
that you are and getting more abuse for
it I'd assume he probably regrets firing
you at the time and like not to say that
he shouldn't have fired me but he could
have easily taken me outside no I think
and I think he he explained it to me
like if you catch some girl cheating on
you and she's at work and you're in the
Next Room if you caught your girl
cheating on you you're gonna be so
[__] pissed you're [__] going in
then you're [__] up her job like and
I was like I get it if like you guys had
that relationship and he truly felt like
what the [__] like
it was short-sighted and that is why
people should not ever make certain
decisions when they're emotional because
you always regret those decisions 100
but I do think that had he handled it a
little bit and I'm sure he admit would
admit the same thing but here's the
thing like to an extent
I and that's what I was kind of going
back and forth in my head was were he
just so mad and I know that was an
element but I honestly think that's
capped to an extent it might be because
there was a moment and the reason why I
think that he thought that he was gonna
dunk on me you feel me and everybody was
just gonna be like oh damn Adam just
[__] marked Lush out right damn Lush
is such a snake [__] him right and they
were gonna be like yeah Adam you're the
man you look so cool because if if he if
this is something he regretted then why
did he post it not only on the no collab
post that's the one thing the collab
post is crazy I think I said that at
lunch because because I think he said my
boy uh arza showed me and I was like oh
he collaposed this so not only the no
jumper fans are gonna see it but his
fans now has gotten millions of views
95 of the comments are on his helmet
like this is a dude that has stated
several times and this isn't a disc to
Adam at all right that you know
ultimately all this aside I do respect
him you know he said
everything is content
everything is fair game you know so I
believe he's like [__] it like oh firing
Lush that's one thing let's fire Lush
ons on the air and then it wound up you
know kind of having an adverse effect
that he hadn't anticipated